desde luego decir que se trata de una
bocanada de aire fresco porque estamos
en presencia de un recambio generacional
es decir es una nueva generación muy
cercana a millennials que llega al
palacio de la moneda pero al mismo
tiempo insistirles que se trata de una
izquierda variopinta el componente
central de esta izquierda es una
izquierda posmoderna con énfasis de lo
identitario en incluir a diversos
colectivos postergados y comunidades que
ha sido discriminada históricamente y
que está en el centro en el corazón de
su programa junto con lo que se ha dicho
el estado de bienestar
señor aranda en su primer discurso
gabriel boric se mostró como un hombre
de consenso de unión y como el
gobernante de todos los chilenos un
mensaje que puede ser muy poderoso para
los chilenos en este momento porque es
un país que está dividido que está muy
polarizado que tanta capacidad tendrá
boliche para congregar para unir a los
chilenos después de los hechos que han
vivido en este gobierno de sebastián
piñera
bueno y fundamentalmente a partir de lo
que fue el estallido social de 18
octubre 2019 con réplicas en varios
países incluso donde me está hablando en
colombia también sin lugar a dudas en un
gran desafío el hablado de alguna manera
de acuerdos y reencuentros estamos
hablando por cierto de un contexto de
segunda vuelta donde se dirigió también
a sectores de más más de mayor
moderación de alguna manera la
centroizquierda también abrió este
candidato que es de izquierdas y por
supuesto con movilización de sectores y
que la herencia del pinochetismo
representado en el señor cast en el
candidato cas le hacía el sentido de
anticuerpos así que podríamos decir que
son muchos los desafíos señor aranda
muchos analistas algunos medios chilenos
usted también mencionaba que se trata de
una nueva generación leyendo los
titulares de la prensa chilena de
algunos que dicen que chile
que en este país terminó la transición y
que ahora está comenzando un nuevo
capítulo en la historia política del
país usted lo ve así
pues la verdad es que muchas veces se ha
hablado del fin de la transición el 94
el 2006 y nuevamente en este caso ahora
lo que sí tenemos una nueva generación
que entra al palacio de la moneda en
chile y tenemos un nuevo sistema de
partido un nuevo orden político que va a
tener otras coordenadas y probablemente
otras prioridades en el sentido bastante
nuevo y hay que decirlo en una bocanada
de aire para la izquierda porque en
latinoamericana porque ciertamente al
menos él el presidente electo boris ha
insistido en un discurso aunque
autoritario que apunte a gobiernos como
los de venezuela y nicaragua usted
menciona venezuela y nicaragua el mismo
el presidente electo gabriel boric ha
criticado a estos gobiernos en estos
países latinoamericanos que
relacionamiento podrá tener a nivel
internacional este nuevo gobierno en
chile dado el mapa político que vemos en
la región hay gobiernos de la derecha de
un extremo como brasil otro gobierno de
derecha como colombia pero vemos otros
gobiernos de izquierdas que pueden ser
grandes aliados de boris en los en este
gobierno que va a empezar como lo ve
usted
bueno básicamente que se adquiere una
mayor sintonía y convergencia política
en los énfasis sociales y económicos con
gobiernos vecinos a chile me estoy
refiriendo a perú bolivia y argentina
pero básicamente en esta hora de esta
luna de miel entre la elección y la
entrada como presidente ya
institucionalmente a la moneda diría que
se van a multiplicar los que esto hace
argentina esa es la sensación que
probablemente con argentina se va a
intentar fortalecer la relación